nos encontramos en salt iscar uno de los
barrios más afectados de la ciudad de
jarquín y este es uno de los más de 700
edificios que está investigando la
fiscalía de esta zona por crímenes de
guerra se trata de un edificio habitado
que era habitado por población civil y
que ha sido atacado el edificio se
encuentra completamente deshabitado en
estos momentos hay restos de escombros
por todas partes estas actividades están
continuando mientras continúan también
los enfrentamientos en esta importante
ciudad ucraniana tanto en el norte como
en el sur hay una ofensiva rusa en el
curso que se ha reactivado en los
últimos días y por otra parte también
continúan los enfrentamientos en la zona
del donbass en particular en las últimas
horas las tropas rusas han avanzado
hacia la ciudad de lichis suns que se
trata de una importante ciudad de esta
zona en conjunto con la ciudad de
severodonezk de hecho una de las dos
ciudades más importantes y más
estratégicas en este momento de la
provincia de no gas que aún no
completamente caído en manos de los
rusos aunque severo de neska se
encuentra prácticamente tomada tomada
con una pequeña resistencia ya desde
hace unos días